good morning this is dr. Charles Hawker
I'm the professor of pathology at
University of Utah School of Medicine in
Salt Lake City and also scientific
director for automation at a RUP
laboratories and it's my pleasure to
present this webinar on how automation
is required in order for a laboratory to
achieve Six Sigma quality in non
analytic metrics first the disclosure
I've already stated i'm an employee of
AR EP laboratories the main objectives
of this presentation art to be sure that
you have a understanding of the
definition of Six Sigma quality and then
we'll will also provide some examples of
activities that you could perform in
your laboratory to improve your non
analytic quality may not be able to
achieve Six Sigma quality but you're
moving in that direction so as an
introduction I think anyone who's
working in the clinical laboratory area
has heard this information many times
clinical laboratories are under
increasing economic pressure this in
turn creates demands for improved
productivity the laboratory workforce is
aging and there's a very inadequate
pipeline of trained replacements for the
people who are retiring or leaving the
field also improving patient safety is a
very important goal and this requires
continuous improvement in both non
analytic and analytic quality in
addition to written processes training
checklists vigilance and a list of other
things that can be undertaken continuous
quality improvement and process
reengineering
using lean and Six Sigma techniques are
really needed to improve quality on an
overall basis and then adding automation
robotics enhanced software and advanced
processes to these written procedures
training checklist vigilance etc is
what's required to push the non analytic
quality to Six Sigma levels however
there are certain activities that each
lab could implement which will improve
their own non analytic quality metrics
without an investment in expensive
automation and this may not lead to six
signal levels but these activities can
still improve quality and I will provide
some examples of those but the main
purpose of the presentation is to show
how automation really is required to get
to to that Six Sigma quality level
because that's very difficult to reach
so what is Six Sigma quality well six
sigma is a process improvement
initiative used to drive defects from
processes it really makes use of
statistics and the goal is to create
near perfection through this continuous
improvement the measured quality is
usually expressed as defects per million
opportunities rdp MO and so I've listed
here on this chart what the error rate
is for 1 Sigma 2 Sigma and so on up to
six sigma and as you can see the defects
per million opportunities for Six Sigma
is only 3.4 defects per million
opportunities which could be per million
tests or per million specimens or some
measure like that in the laboratory but
opportunities can refer to more than
just specimens or tests because you
might count different handling steps as
an opportunity for an error or
thing on that sort in our lab sections
in our laboratory the threshold for
corrected reports is two per 10,000 so
if you just simply look at this chart of
the signal levels 5 Sigma is 233 errors
per million which is two point three
three per 10,000 so the threshold for
good performance in our technical
laboratory sections is slightly more
than 5 Sigma but I can assure you that
that's a very challenging goal and I
think if you look at your own error
levels in your own laboratory you'll see
why six sigma is so elusive and so
difficult to reach it's it's nearly 80
times more difficult than 5 Sigma so
this chart about error rates I have
modified from presentations done by my
caste ian at the University of
Washington and the Seattle Children's
Hospital and he in turn based this chart
on a published report by dr. racer and
the citation is given at the bottom of
the slide there down the left side are
different error rates from 1 to 1,000 to
1 to 1 million and in the center are
some different processes and methods
that might be used to achieve those
error rates and then on the right are
some examples of certain activities in a
laboratory setting that probably meet
those particular error rates and as I
said this is a slide that was originally
presented by dr. Aston so for example
hand washing
you require all employees to wash their
hands as they're leaving the laboratory
before they go anywhere else but clearly
some employees forget to do it what do
you think the error rate is for that
well I suspect it's worse than one in
1,000 but for most of our laboratories
but perhaps I'm mistaken in that
assumption but in any case in order to
train or teach employees to wash their
hands as leaving the laboratory you have
clear processes you do can in a very
important education about it there's
training and there's vigilance and
employees tend to police each other even
if the supervisors not there to watch an
employee's wash their hands so that's an
example of a process and that maybe
achieves the one in 1,000 error rate and
then there are some examples of things
that are at the one in 10,000 error rate
for example requisition order errors or
suboptimal specimens there are some
examples of measures that are at the one
to 100,000 error rate dr. Aston has
mislabeled specimens and corrected
reports and then there's examples of
error rates at the 12 1,000,000 which he
lists lost specimens interfaced result
entry and barcode reading however I in
particular because of my many years of
experience in the laboratory I don't
particularly agree with dr. Ashton's
estimations on time the the I believe
that there are many published reports
about mislabeled specimens that show the
error rates to be much worse than the
one to 100,000 that he had in the
previous slide
their numerous reports published of CA p
to probe studies that show error rates
on the order of one and two thousand or
one and three thousand and so it's our
one in 1000 and I even know report where
the error rate for labeled specimens in
blood banks in clinical laboratories was
worse than 1% one per 100 so I have
simply moved mislabeled specimens up a
grouping here to the one and ten
thousand lost specimens I have moved up
from the 1 and 1 million to one in
100,000 because again i have 40 years of
experience and I know that specimens get
lost and I know what our experience has
been at our laboratory at a RUP and one
in 1,000,000 is better than six sigma
and so I know how difficult that would
be to achieve so what I want to do over
these next few slides is show you the
history of lost specimens in our
laboratory across the base line on the
bottom of the slide is and I'm moving
the cursor along the bottom of the slide
and hopefully you all can see that the
are the years starting in nineteen
ninety one through 2013 and the ordinate
is a log scale of the ratio of lost
specimens per 100,000 total specimens so
starting at the very top we have 100
lost specimens per 100,000 total
specimens or one per 1000 and then the
next major mark is
100 / 100 top excuse me 10 per 100,000
the next mark is one per 100,000 and
then at the bottom is 0.1 per 100,000 so
the Six Sigma line is indicated by this
green line which would be 0.3 for per
100,000 are the 3.4 per million rdp mo
the 5 Sigma line is the red line 23.3
per 100,000 and you could see this
history that we go back a slight you
could see this history for these the
first early years from 1991 through 1997
of a an improvement in the rate of lost
specimens because we were we were
tracking it and because there was a
significant process improvement
indicated by this slide which in this
case was not allowing our lab sections
to directly call the clients to request
a replacement specimen because the
specimen had been lost we simply allowed
the labs to tell client services please
call the client we don't we can't find
the specimen and it turned out we knew
that we hadn't lost them we we had
misplaced them and we set up a process
which required it this to be reviewed
before the client would be called and so
this process of not letting that call go
out directly but doing a review and a
search for the specimen we eliminated
many of those phone calls and that's
where you see this decline an
improvement in the rate of lost
specimens so then shown on this chart is
a whole group of monthly versus that
previously those were annual figures
these are monthly measures of lost
specimens per 100,000 total specimens
extending from about 1998 to 2003 so
adding on to the previous chart and you
can see it this downward trend sort of
continues mostly in the first several
years and then it sort of seems to level
off a bit from 2001 2003 well there were
two things that happened that
contributed to this information this
data first we made some significant
automation we installed a transport and
sorting system which also included
storage sorting and we made a process of
improvement which was to go from an
assembly line process in our specimen
processing to a individual workstations
where each employee was responsible for
the entire process of ordering the tests
or checking the order if it had been
transmitted through an interface and and
then labeling the specimen verifying it
labeling the specimen and so on so by
making instead of having those steps
split up in an assembly line they were
all handled by one employee and it was
actually more efficient but it was also
it also reduced errors and in this case
it also contributed to reducing lost
specimens so here's just an example of
that early automation that was installed
in 1998 a conveyor system these were
lines that fed into this loop conveyor
system there are three high-speed
sorters for sorting specimens for the
labs and a sorter for storage sorting so
then this chart shows lost specimens
from 2003
to about two thousand and eight or nine
added on so now you can see this
downward trend continuing on a pretty
continuous basis with a big with a big
drop starting in 2003 or 2004 and then
it sort of does admittedly level off a
little bit so again we had process
improvements and we had automation that
contributed to these improvements that
followed this leveling off period in
2003 for automation we had a major
expansion of that track transport and
sorting system including more sorters
and we installed our automated robotic
storage freezer our ASRs and for process
improvement we had really automate the
whole process for storage and retrieval
and and that storage system made a
tremendous improvement in reducing our
lost specimen rates so here now you see
the expanded track system here's all of
specimen processing and there are eight
high-speed sorters sorting the specimens
for the tests and this on the right is
the two-story storage freezer which is
shown in this following slide just a
simple CAD drawing and you see a annum
figure of an employee at one end where
specimens would be retrieved and all of
these are storage shelves that are
accessed by robotic systems this that
system can hold 2.3 million specimens
and we can retrieve a specimen in about
two and a half minutes on average then
here is the completion of the chart so
you see from 2008 to 2013 again a
continual can decline in the rate of
loss
assessments per 100,000 total specimens
received again this is as I said at the
beginning this is a log scale through
here and there are three dots that are
shown in green because those three
monthly points have crossed the Six
Sigma line what were the improvements
that led to this latest decline well one
was the installation of a sort to light
system the sort to light system was an
automation system invented in house to
sort based on the barcode those
specimens that were not placed on the
automated track system it's what we
would call manual specimens and a
process improvement they also
contributed to this was the installation
of what we call pods and specimen
processing department so this is the
sort to light system sort of a little
bit like reminds you maybe of Hollywood
Squares the employee has a one of these
manual specimens that can't go on the
track in their hand they read the
barcode and this little light at square
lights up and that's the bin that they
place that specimen in it has eliminated
a lot of miss sorted specimens because
previously they had to read the label to
find the department or lab section where
that specimen was supposed to go and so
a lot of specimens were getting miss
sorted and miss delivered and then we
had to trust that people would bring
them back or whatever so that's the sort
delight system and there's a section
kiss for ambient specimens and a section
for frozen specimens and another section
for refrigerated specimens we're now
building more of those systems to to
greatly expand that thing and then here
is the specimen processing department
and you see these what are called pods
may be hard to see unless you're you're
looking at this full screen but
employees are seated together in
clusters of four so the forum
please all work on a shipment at the
same time together it makes those
employees more efficient and all of the
specimens from the same client would be
there together so if one employees
working on the frozens and another one's
working on the refrigerators or whatever
it it makes them more efficient and less
likely to lose a specimen or misplace a
specimen so we've talked a bit about six
sigma analysis and I've given you the
definition already of 3.4 defects per
million opportunities in the case of
lost specimens each time a specimen is
handled is really an opportunity that
the employee could misplace it or lose
it and since our laboratory has an
average of one point six build units or
tests per specimen it's really each test
that represents an opportunity to lose
the specimen because they each test is a
separate handling of that specimen
therefore I think a more correct
assessment of Six Sigma quality is not
using total lost specimens as the
denominator but using total build units
as the denominator and so that's shown
on the next slide and we can't go back
to the early years prior to nineteen
ninety-seven because the the government
changed the definition of build units in
1997 but this is the same data from the
previous slides that I showed you
through 2013 but simply using a hundred
thousand total build units as the
denominator and now you can see there
are nine green dots that are below the
Six Sigma line and I've already
explained how all this automation and
process improvement is what drove us to
that quality level we're continuing to
make numerous in
improvements to our automation and I
think there's still an opportunity to
drive this trend even further so let me
go back to dr. Ashton's chart and the
overall contention that he made that
automation robotics software
enhancements advanced process design is
what's really necessary to drive quality
down towards six signal levels and we're
not quite at 121 million but I think you
can see from the data that I presented
that lost specimens we are certainly
down in the neighborhood of better than
one to 100,000 for most of those if you
see on this chart this is this black
line is the one per 100,000 so most of
those are now better than that and with
some points at book better than 0.34 per
100,000 so at Six Sigma levels let's
talk a bit about mislabeled specimens as
the other example that I've highlighted
here so mislabeled specimens the United
States and at our laboratory I mentioned
that there are some published data about
mislabeled specimens and depending on
the publication the error rates range
from a point oh four percent to as high
as five percent in some of these
different published studies so one Early
College of American Pathologists q probe
study that was published in the archives
of pathology in lab medicine by valence
teen and Rab and their colleagues showed
an error rate of 0.39 per 100,000 then a
couple of years later
there was a public publication of
another CA PQ probe study 147 us
clinical labs participated voluntarily
in this study and the overall error rate
was almost 1 per 1,000 0.9 0.92 I think
for 100 per 1,000 specimens again
published in the archives of pathology
and lab medicine a third kpq probe study
was published in 2010 in this case 122
us laboratories that had blood bank
operations and they reported an average
incidence of mislabeled specimens of 1.1
2% now I don't want people to walk away
thinking that the country's blood supply
is in danger because of mislabeled
specimens these errors were corrected
before there was any patient safety
concern it's just a mislabeling that
handled in the first step of the process
and then a subsequent step it was
corrected but but this gives you an idea
of how significant this the mislabeled
specimen issue is in the United States
in our laboratory our historic measured
error rate in specimen processing was
about one per 10,000 so perhaps one
quarter to one tenth of those a
published levels above in addition we
believe that our quote downstream
inspections and corrections we're
finding and correcting about ninety-five
percent of those errors of one and ten
thousand so that errors that got out the
door that escaped our inspection were
perhaps on the order of one per 200,000
so that's what we believed however we
felt that that wasn't good enough a
mislabeled specimen is is quite
significant
and here is a summary that is available
on the c AP website and there's a
citation or link at the bottom of the
slide concerning a poster presented by
one of my colleagues dr. Steve Khan at
Loyola University giving an average
hypothetical cost of a mislabeled
specimen of seven hundred and twelve
dollars which excludes patient anxiety
and discomfort delays and diagnosis and
treatment and all of that but it's
really the administrative charges
associated with recollecting and
retesting the specimen the read Ribery
the patient taking off of work or coming
in to have a specimen redrawn and so
forth these were not actual incurred
costs but they were the cost that that
might have been billed to third party
payers or whatever if the error was
followed up in that fashion and on the
caap website that has this discussion
they have taken the incidents of
mislabeled specimens published by we go
back to that they've taken the incidents
published by valence teen and RAB in
archives mythology and lab medicine of
point 39 per 1000 and simply multiplied
it by the 712 dollars in hypothetical
costs for each mislabel and it simply
means if you do the math that for every
1 million specimens tested in the United
States 280 thousand dollars in costs are
added to the US healthcare system so
that's a pretty significant number
because we obviously know that many many
millions of tests are being
done so in our laboratory we decided we
would try to drive mislabeled specimens
20 and for the past eight years I've
been involved in a research project to
develop a high-speed automated camera
system that could photograph the outside
of a specimen to the entire labels that
are on the outside of the tube and use
optical character recognition or OCR to
see if that specimen has been mislabeled
so this is a little schematic simply
showing a conveyor system with
cylindrical objects moving down a
conveyor and here are four cameras each
aimed their equidistant equidistantly
spaced and they're each aimed at the
tube or the part and then the system
assembles the four photographs into a
single photograph so you're taking a
cylindrical or three-dimensional image
of the outside of the tube and you've
made it into a two-dimensional image and
then you can do OCR analysis that's the
principle this is a CAD drawing of the
system next to our automated conveyor
and at this point we're going to play a
video for you of the system in operation
this video clip shows the operation of
the system that was developed to detect
mislabeled specimens
as shown in this scene specimens are
being transported in carriers on our
automation system they are stopped at a
precise point enabling a robot to pick
the tubes out of the carrier and lift
them up to the vision system this
stopping point is directly in front of a
red backlight and with the aid of a
45-degree mirror a smart camera which is
shown in the right foreground measures
the tubes height and the diameter of the
cap this enables the robot to securely
grasp the cap and lift the tube
this view shows more of the entire
system the robot is on the right on the
left is the operators computer screen
which shows each image as it is acquired
and the results of the OCR analysis in
this view of course all protected health
information has been blurred so that it
can't be read however you can see the
screen change to a new image as each
tube is photographed and analyzed the
cycle time for one tube ranges from 2.5
to 3.5 seconds depending on the quality
of the label
this view again shows the transport
carriers with tubes arriving at the
stopping point where the robot will lift
them to the vision system on the left
you can see the 45-degree mirror that
the smart camera uses to measure the
tubes dimensions to guide the robot
incorrectly picking up the tube by its
cap
this view from the top shows the robot
and vision system there are four equally
spaced cameras with four reflective
panels and four strobe lights as you can
see from this pause in the video the
strobe lights are very bright the vision
system software precisely stitches the
four separate photographs into a single
photograph which is the entire exterior
of the tube and is so sharp that OCR can
be performed
okay so how does this OCR system
classify images you saw the photograph
of the outside of the specimen container
the tube and a portion of that is the
ARU p label and a portion of that is the
customer's label and from the ARU
p-labeled barcode our lis provides the
patient named as a character string and
then the system looks on the area
outside of the AR EP label on other
words the customer label to our client
label to see if it can find a matching
character string that matches what's in
our lis so if a character string is
found on this client label that is an
exact match for what is in the patient
name field in RL is the image is
classified as a pass if there's only a
single label on the specimen tube then
that image is an automatic pass or what
we call pass as a single it might have
been mislabeled but we have no way to
know that so if there's only one label
on the tube it's an automatic pass if
there is a client label on the tube but
it has no exactly matching character
string that can be found the images are
failed however it doesn't mean it was a
Miss label there are many reasons for
fails poor label quality unusual fonts
name being partially covered by
handwriting or a felt-tip marker or by
the areare p label are our own label
might cover part of the patient name the
name could have been truncated by the
client they could have transmitted into
the lis John Henry Jones but on the
label they only printed Jones comma john
h or something like that as an example
in other words there's a truncation
names that are turned at 90 degrees to
the direction of the tube also we get
interference from colored labels and
striped labels and things like that so
everything that is a fail is going to be
inspected by an employee and somewhere
among all of those fails will be the
Miss labels so the whole objective is to
have the computer system pass as many
specimens as it can possibly pass and
then we are minimizing how many we have
to inspect by hand so here's an example
of a label inspection result which was
classified as a pass this photograph
that's in grayscale is the client label
portion of the photograph up here so
here's the barcode that's used to query
our lis find out the patient name in
this particular example the client
transmitted to us to our computer system
a dummy name of test comma Jodie jod I
space dnd so that's in our computer
system that's what we've learned when we
look up from this barcode and now we're
looking on the client label or what is
shown a little bit easier to see on this
gray scale image for test comma Jodie
dnd and there it is so this result is a
pass however in the next example the
client transmitted an image that was had
a numeric and we chose this so we could
illustrate we could illustrate the big
performance of the system is not just
Alpha characters but also numeric
characters so the patient name that was
transmitted was test comma DTS
excuse me let's look at the label that
what the client transmitted was test
comedy TS 4587 and we intentionally
changed that 72 and 8 in our lis after
we had received the order to create a
mismatch between the printed label
printed by the client and what our
computer system was looking for for we
were looking for the 88 and the client
had sent us the 87 so it was a failed
I'm showing you here the very first
mislabeled specimens that were caught by
this OCR system in October of 2012 these
were twin sisters Linda and Brenda who
were drawn by the same physician same
client same date and time for the same
test I think we've blacked out medical
record numbers and last names but
fructosamine was the test that was
ordered but you can see that on the aru
p label in the lower one be it says
Brenda and the customer label says Linda
and then on the other one on the AR EP
label that says Linda and the customer
label says Brenda so they were just
switched and this is a very common
occurrence and it does occur on patients
who have whose names aren't even similar
like they were in this one but this was
missed by our employees both in the
specimen processing and the technical
section that performed the testing and
in fact the technologists that I was
working with when I asked her did you
catch this air no we didn't and she says
boy we were set up to fail on that one
just speaking because the names were so
similar so that's how the system works
so we did a validation study of a
million specimens
between October of 2012 and the end of
May of 2013 and the objectives of the
validation study were first to minimize
the total number of tubes that failed
due to poor label quality font training
in correct positioning all the other
reasons that I gave you on the previous
slide these would be what we would call
false fails they are correctly labeled
there's not an error it's just that the
system can't read the photograph for
quality issues related to the photograph
but we're trying to minimize all that
human inspection or manual work and our
target as we entered the validation
study was to have an 80% pass rate or a
20-percent fail rate so eighty percent
true passes and twenty percent false
fails in addition our objectives were
that every mislabeled tube had to be a
failure a fail so those would be
so-called true fails and would be picked
up through the manual inspection process
our target there's one hundred percent
the inverse of that is is that we had to
absolutely guarantee that no mislabeled
tubes would ever slip through the system
and be automatically passed by the
system in other words zero percent for
false passes so those were the
objectives of the validation study which
as I said was completed may thirty first
of 2013 we had over a million images
every one of those million images was
reviewed either by myself or one of four
other employees I can tell you that was
a lot of work but it was necessary to
validate the system the overall pass
rate was not eighty percent as we had
hoped it was about 75% we still have
hopes that we can get that up to closer
to eighty percent and minimize the human
labor labor involved in inspecting all
of those fails the important thing was
was we had no false passes there
were no mislabeled specimens that
slipped through and were passed by the
system out of seven hundred and
forty-three thousand total passes among
the mislabeled specimens in the
validation study of which there were 121
what we learned was was that first of
all the rate that we thought we had
which was one to ten thousand based on
the historic data collected by the
specimen processing Department the ratio
was actually a little bit higher one per
8346 not bad still better than those see
AP publications but not as good as what
we had thought based on the data we were
capturing but this is difficult data to
capture because it requires on all sorts
of after the fact investigation requires
clients to call if they have detected an
error that sort of thing so that's why
the tendency is to miss some of your
errors without an automated system like
we're using here so we were actually
quite pleased with this overall
performance level from our specimen
processing department that they only
mislabeled one specimen out of every
8300 out of those 121 mislabeled
specimens 71 were found by the testing
laboratory our editors before testing
but we had to send 46 of those on for
investigation for possible correction
reports and we ended up with 21
corrected reports now not always is a
corrected report required if the tests
are repeated and the results are the
same after the specimens have been
correctly labeled then there's no need
for a corrected report and so there are
different scenarios in which you correct
the report would not be required but we
did end up sending out 21 corrected
reports out of those 121 miss labels one
of the values of the system however is
that we also find specimens which we
call
mismatch they're primarily spelling
errors so for example the client label
has a patient named Kristin kri st en
and our label our laboratories label has
Kristin spelled Kri STI n so te an
or-tis it's the same patient the medical
record numbers the date of birth
collection dating all the other
parameters match it's just that spelling
error if all of those other parameters
match we continue on with testing but if
those other parameters don't match where
our policies are to call the client and
verify that the patient and spelling and
make sure what we report is the correct
spelling as it turns out this system
found 148 of those so-called mismatched
names and employees had only found about
a third of those prior to testing so
that's an additional value of this OCR
system and we were very fortunate to
have the publication on this system
accepted and published in clinical
chemistry in March of this year a couple
of months ago and and it was a great
honor to have that article accompanied
by an editorial by dr. Robin Felder so
the current results on this system
through last week are we've now run 2.87
million images the mislabel ratio has
dropped a bit to one in 7,500 still
better than the published reports from
the College of American Pathologists but
of those 382 miss labels 50 about fifty
four percent 207 were found prior to
testing we also have identified entered
in 19 specimens as mismatched or with
spelling errors
and we're identifying our employees are
finding about twenty eight percent of
those prior to testing as of last week
we've sent 40 corrected reports to
clients now that's not that much bigger
a number than the 21 before it turns out
that in February of 2013 we moved this
system from one automated track to a
different automated track the first
track that the system was on delivered
the specimens to our high volume
automated core laboratory where
specimens are tested non-stop 24 hours a
day seven days a week and they test so
quickly that they don't often catch the
airs and so 17 of the errors were
wildest but the specimens were being
delivered to the core lab and they had a
total of six hundred thirty six thousand
specimens that for which we had
collected images and done OCR analysis
so that error ratio was one corrected
report for every thirty seven thousand
four hundred and sixteen images that we
collected with the system when we moved
that system to a different track the
specimens went to a different laboratory
section that wasn't running their tests
every day of the week it's the
immunology laboratory some of them the
testing as higher volume and is is run
constantly but some of it is lower
volume and some of the tests are run
twice a week or three times a week or
that sort of thing and what that meant
was was that the OCR was actually in
time I should mention that we don't
review these OCR images right on the
spot the review by an employee is the
next day or in the case of weekend
specimens it's on Monday so it's after
the fact but in the case of the
laboratory section immunology
where the testing is not done constantly
often we were able to tell them of this
error before testing was completed our
testing was even started and so the
error rate has dropped significantly the
corrected reports sent to clients has
dropped to a ratio of 14 97,000 just
simply showing what the power of this
system is and that if we can promptly
review those images will in fact
eliminate any corrected reports and
that's that's our ultimate goal we're
going to be building four more of these
systems as shown by these arrows across
here here's our four different tracks
and specimen processing we're going to
build four more of these systems in this
coming year and we will set up for
employees to review those images
promptly and we believe we can drive
corrected reports related to mislabeled
specimens to near zero so what can you
do in your laboratory to improve your
quality I've talked about lost specimens
and Miss and Miss labeled specimens but
let me just give you some ideas that you
can do that don't involve these
sophisticated automation that we have in
our laboratory so reducing lost
specimens is all about tracking even if
you don't have Adam automation you need
to have some mechanisms for tracking the
specimens where they're going and who's
handling them you can use your L is to
track specimens from specimen processing
in our Cerner lis system we have a
status called central collect which is
the status the specimens are in once
they have been ordered in specimen
processing once they're delivered to the
lab sections they're brought to what's
called in lab status in the cerner
system
this requires an extra barcode read in
the labs to verify the receipt of the
specimens but it's a useful tracking
step to have the labs read the barcode
on the specimen once the specimens in
their hands for specimens being
transported to the lab from clinics or
affiliated hospitals I believe you could
use barcodes to create transfer lists so
you'd have a transfer list of 20 or 30
specimens or however many and that whole
sheet transfer list number such-and-such
would have a barcode you just read one
barcode and you're essentially taking
receipt of the transfer of those
specimens from point A to point B you
can require employees to check out the
specimens if you have a centralized
storage system in many laboratories
employees just simply go in the computer
system and find the location of the
stored specimen tray Iraq number
such-and-such row number column number
and so on and they take the specimen
nobody knows who took the specimen we
had that going on in our laboratory for
a while until finally everybody got
frustrated I had said from the beginning
require employees to check specimens out
and no one believed me finally after
several years they took my advice and
and we don't allow employees to get
specimens without entering their ID in
fact it's a bar code based system so
they have to use their employee badge
which has a bar code if you don't have
your badge you can't checkout specimens
mislabeled specimens can be reduced by
using wireless bedside phlebotomy
systems where the wireless system
queries the lis gets the current orders
Prince specimen labels for those orders
you're at the patient bedside and so
that process is initiated by reading the
patient's wristband barcode not that
many labret laboratories or hospitals
are set up with this kind of a system
yet probably in the neighborhood of
twenty percent but that's something that
although expensive is a huge step
towards reducing mislabeled specimens
also I strongly recommend that
laboratories implement the clsi standard
auto 12 a on specimen label formats what
is the clsi standard auto 12 a it was a
standard published three years ago in
which the format for a label as shown on
these two examples specifies patient
name on the top line of the label as our
committee reviewed a lot of different
label formats we found the patient name
anywhere on the label from first line
second line third line fourth line fifth
line above the barcode below the barcode
left justified right justified sometimes
in the middle and sometimes turned 90
degrees to the orientation of the rest
of the label and the orientation of the
tube and so this standard is not
concerned with the barcode that's a
different clsi standard auto to but this
standard is concerned with the human
readable content so patient name and
their in in the standard are specified
font types font sizes and formats so
patient name on the first line unique
secondary identifier usually a medical
record number or financial number is on
the second line left justified right
justified is patient date of birth age
and sex then below the barcode left
justified is the collection date and
time and a phlebotomist ID and the rest
of the region below the barcode is left
for the laboratory to choose for their
optional information and there's a
version of this label that has a
priority code down the left side of the
label so this priority code would be
easily visible if the tubes were in Iraq
or whatever because the standard
requires that these labels be placed so
they're readable as they are now if the
top of the tube the capper the stopper
is on the left end of the is to the left
of the label so in summary experience in
our laboratory over 22 years in
implementing process improvements in
automation has led to a steady reduction
in Los specimens to a level consistently
below 1 per 100,000 build units and some
months in the Six Sigma region in other
words less than point 3 4 per 100,000
also we have new OCR technology for
identifying possible mislabeled
specimens and this technology has the
prospect of perhaps someday achieving
Six Sigma quality levels when we have it
fully implemented on our automation and
I have provided several improvement
suggestions for use in your laboratories
that can offer opportunities to achieve
meaningful reductions in error rates
without some of these expensive
automation systems so thank you and on
this slide is the information about
where you can get continuing education
credits at this point I'm happy to take
questions and I i will look at the
questions that have been submitted and
read them and give you some responses so
the first the first question is did we
investigate errors on PT risk barcode we
have not however that has been published
in clinical chemistry by a group from
Emory University the first author's name
was Snyder synd er I don't have the
citation in front of me but I'm going to
say it was fall of 2011 or 2012 and I'm
sorry I can't be more specific but the
Emery group investigated barcode errors
associated with the the wristband
barcodes and primarily most of the
errors were occurring with different
point of care reading devices so their
overall project they improved the
quality of the wristband barcodes but
then they standardized on some of the
barcode reading devices and added check
digits and a number of other
improvements and it's a very informative
article so that appears to be the only
question that was submitted so with that
I thank you for attending this
conference today I've enjoyed presenting
it to you and I hope you will look at
other bio conference live presentations
thank you very much
you